[Aplausos]
muchas gracias primero que nada por
estar aquí mientras yo estoy hablando
con ustedes una menor de edad está
siendo atacada cada 4.8 minutos violan
una niña en mexico no hay un solo
momento piénsenlo mientras estás
comiendo mientras te estás bañando y
mientras estoy aquí con ustedes hay una
niña que está siendo violada claro eso
sin mencionar que 7 de cada 10 actos de
violencia sexual no son ni reportados ni
denunciados estoy aquí hoy con ustedes
porque soy de ese 38.9 por ciento de las
mujeres que ha sufrido algún tipo de
violencia sexual esto equivale al doble
de la población de la ciudad de mexico
sería lo mismo que llenar el estadio
azteca trescientas veces con mujeres que
hemos sido víctimas empecemos por
entender que la violencia sexual puede
ir desde una violación a un comentario
inapropiado desde un piropo desde un
piropo ofensivo hasta los tocamientos
sin el consentimiento de la otra persona
la violencia es un tema del que pocas
personas hablan pero que está
constantemente en nuestra sociedad
mientras fue estudiando más el problema
me di cuenta que lo tenemos tan
introyectado y normal
dado que actuamos casi de manera
automática tenemos en nuestra sociedad
una cultura de violencia y por cultura
de violencia me refiero a los
pensamientos contenido cultural forma de
relacionarnos que suceden dentro de
nuestra sociedad que promueve la
violencia de una u otra forma por
ejemplo cuando nos llega la foto de una
mujer desnuda en todos nuestros grupos
de amigos de whatsapp cuando le decimos
una mujer [ __ ] solamente por su forma de
vestirse o por disfrutar de su libertad
sexual inclusive cuando escuchamos
canciones que denigran estas mujeres
estamos promoviendo esta violencia
al observar analizar y estudiar más el
problema porque llevo dos años
estudiando y analizándolo me di cuenta
que no son las víctimas ni los
violentadores sino que son los
espectadores los que tienen el poder de
hacer un cambio
analicemos el caso de un alcalde en un
pueblo de nayarit quien levantó la falda
y tomó las pompas de una menor de edad
mientras gran parte del auditorio solo
se reía y aplaudía esta forma de pensar
y actuar es una enfermedad social porque
estamos permitiendo esto porque no
cuidamos a las mujeres ya las niñas de
nuestra propia sociedad se necesita cero
tolerancia en estas conductas deber es
una vergüenza nacional pero en méxico se
ignora por completo el problema
entendamos que la violencia sexual es
algo que vivimos día a día lo que
estamos haciendo como sociedad no está
funcionando
estamos aplicando medidas de prevención
terciaria que son cuando el problema ya
está instaurado y debemos evitar que
éste empeore pero nos hemos olvidado que
debemos aplicar un tipo de prevención
básica la que va a la tasa de la
violencia sexual la prevención primaria
la educación la forma de relacionarnos
la forma en que educamos a nuestros
propios hijos deben de tener esta
educación solamente en enero de este año
solamente en pueblo se han registrado un
90 feminicidios 90 y seguimos
permitiendo que esto pase
la violencia es algo que tenemos tan
introyectado que actuamos casi de manera
automática como ya lo dije y el estado
ha generado una alerta de violencia de
género dentro del país esto se traduce
en acciones que el gobierno y el estado
han hecho para poder erradicar estos
crímenes de odio hacia las mujeres
pero ni separándonos en vagones de tren
ni siquiera enseñándonos técnicas de
defensa personal ni siquiera aplicando
legislaciones más rigurosas en contra
los violentadores han hecho que este
problema cerrado se radique y por fin
podamos terminar con la violencia
así me parece que cuando hablamos de
este tema hay muchas activistas muchas
jóvenes inclusive víctimas como yo que
discuten y hablan del tema y lo tratan
de visualizar pero por qué sigue
ocurriendo esto se está tan hablado
pareciera ser que las personas ya están
tan llenas de la cabeza de este tema que
ya completamente están de sensibilizadas
pero quién está hablando de las
soluciones quien habla de hacer un
cambio dentro de la sociedad dentro de
la sociedad cómo podemos ponerle un fin
a esta violencia empezando desde casa
desde nuestras dinámicas familiares
cuando permitimos que a una mujer le
hable con un lenguaje degradante y
degradante que [ __ ] así son las mujeres
está en sus días son frases que
escuchamos todo el tiempo y nadie hace
nada es por eso que yo estoy aquí con
ustedes compartiendo les el poder que
tenemos como sociedad para hacer un
cambio empecemos por pequeñas acciones
desde que te llegó una foto desnuda de
una mujer en lugar de reenviarla todos
tus grupos de whatsapp y morita la risa
con tus amigos
eliminar la inclusivo munro pboc aquí
mismo en la universidad que se subieron
esas fotos
hay que eliminar este tipo de conductas
entre las mujeres nosotras mismas nos
criticamos nos insultamos que [ __ ]
quienes ella son cosas que debemos
acabar en situaciones de peligro y de
emergencia al levantar la voz y ser ser
un agente de cambio en lugar de quedarse
como espectador
hoy les vengo a compartir este mensaje
quiero decirles que
cuando yo fui víctima de violencia
sexual nadie hizo nada y yo estaba en un
auditorio casi como el de ustedes lleno
de gente y nadie se paró nadie hizo nada
para decirme hoy estás bien te ayudo hoy
les vengo a transmitir que hoy tenemos
una promesa entre nosotros para hacer
algo para hacer un cambio y en lugar de
ser espectadores movernos más allá y ser
agentes de cambio los invito a unirse
este movimiento para que los próximos
cinco minutos evitemos que una niña sea
víctima de violencia sexual gracias
m
[Aplausos]